رسول
اشهد
محمد
اما بعد
بوث الامام البخاري امام مسلم رحمهم الله
‏are
before
we have at least
states the messenger الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ان لله تعالى
99 اسما
الا واحده
ان لله تعالى
99 اسما
100 الا واحده
من احصاها
دخل الجنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم الله
الله
‏gather them
and encompasses them will enter paradis
now before we take a look into the
meaning of this narration many of us
have heard this before
and one of the misconceptions that
people may
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم mention
that الله
‏are 99
سنه
الله محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏paradante
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
الاحصاء
في لغه العرب هو الجمع والاحاطه
احصى
الاحصاء
احصاها
number
مع الفهم
الاحصاء
هو ان يدعو الله
الله
الثالث هو العمل بمقتضاها
وبمقتضى الايمان
‏the meaning of these names in life put
the meanings of these names and the
implications of these names
that they have effect on the person's
life.
‏number
to understand them clearly
which even in the word in English
encompass or gather it means that so the
person first learns these names and
understands their meaning
number two the person
starts to work these names into his
dialog and vocabulary
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ولله الاسماء الحسنى فادعوه بها الله
سبحانه وتعالى tell
‏and understand
these names and understand how himself
uses in
the person
formulate vo
and them in prayers الله سبحانه وتالى
name
particular
this is
التوسل
notسل
متاخرين توسل
توسل
‏here
by prop
name الله
as a make her pray
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله انت الرحمن الرحيم
فارحمني
انت الجبار فاجبرني
انت الشافي فاشفني هذا هو التوسل الذي كان
يقوم به رسول الله وصحابته
الكرام
‏and
apprate name to
and the third is these names have impact
on a person life
they they ad to the implications of
these names
whatever the description of Allah that
is derived from the name they are
mindful of that and it starts to aff
their spe their actions
الله سبحانه وى
الله صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
لا يوجد حديث يصح سنده واسناده
عن رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يذكر
جميع ويسرد هذه الاسماء ال0
كل ما جاء فيه ذكر الاسماء مسروده فهي
ضعيفه عند الترمذي وعند غيره ويكاد الحفاظ
ان يتفقوا على ضعف هذه الروايات
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
عن الترمذي
في سنن ابن ماجه وعند
حديث
all those narrations have we ch of
narration
and some the names that are mentioned in
those narrations are not actually names
of Allah and other names that ar mention
are of the names of mention in the qu
even
and that would defeat the purpose
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يغفر لنا خطايانا وان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا
وان ينفعنا بما علمنا نساله سبحانه وتعالى
ا ان يعلمنا
هذه الاسماء وان يوفقنا جميعا لاحصائها
وحفظها وفهمها والعمل بها ودعائه بها وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين
وجزاكم الله خيرا
‏.